PANTHERS
HERE'S JOKIHARJU STRAIGHT ON,
OLOFSSON, SAME SPOT, THAT TIME
D
HE SCORES .
POSITION.
IN THE GAME IS TIED.
THERE'S A POWER-PLAY GOAL.
MARK PYSYK AND HE SCORES.
THERE'S ANOTHER LOOK AT IT
LOMBERG IS IN.  MBERG LEADING T
WAY.
THE FIFI OPPORTUNITIES THAT THE
ARE LOOKING FOR  AND THE SABRES
ARE LITTLE SLOPPY AND
ON THE BACKHAND.
JEFF SKINNER MAKES IT 3 - 1
SABRESON THE GOAL LINE AND
SKINNER, THEY TALK ABOUT THE
SKILL SET.
WHAT A
THEY PLAYED CAROLINA, LOMBERG
GETS IN, LOMBERG SHOOTS,  STEP
DEFENSEMEN, STAYS ON THE
FOREHAND BUT TOKARSKI WITH HIS
BEST SAVE OF THE PERIOD SO FAR.
LOMBERG  LOOKED LIKE
AGGRESSIVE FOR CHECKING IN THE
SKATES IN AND GIVES IT
TO BEEN.
OUT IN
UP HIGH, WEEGAR MA
MONTOUR INTO THE SLOT, CARRIES,
SHOOTS, SAVE, , THEN
THE PASS PUT IN FRONT.
FORSLINGHAVE COME BACK AND TIED
THE GAME AGAIN. SHOOT, SAVE THE
BOTH GOALS.DELL KICKS IT AHEAD.
GETS UP TO THE SHOOTING.
GETS TO IT,  BACKHANDER, SAVE
OFOF
>> RANDY: AT THE END OF THE
POWER-PLAY A TRY TO GET
THERE. CHASING AFTER DAHLIN,
REINHART WITH  BIT. B
>> STEVE: AND ANOTHER SAVE BY
TOKARSKI KEEPING IT ON THE
REBO
NOW IT'S DAHLIN FIRING CROSS
ICE, PICKED UP IN FRONT.
THE CHANCE,  BROSKI WABARKOV,
BENNETT.